it is my absolute pleasure to introduce
azamat um alif and he is going to talk
about I think a very relevant topic that
is overlooked so much so are you solving
a problem that actually makes sense I
know I've fallen into this trap and
built something very cool which nobody
ever looked at again so I'm very
interested in hearing how we should go
about this let's have a big round of
applause
thanks for the nice introduction Lanna
uh indeed I hope that uh if you joined
this talk um if you really liked the
talk of Vincent from the morning the
keynote and if parts of it resonated
well with you uh I hope that you'll find
parts of this talk also interesting
because at the end uh when he talked
about how mlops helps build models that
last um I think that's really important
to get right but today also uh want to
talk about how to build models that
actually build pro uh solve problems so
um that's kind of the a bit of a
takeaway but let's start from the basics
yes this works um so my name is aat and
I work at in uh it's probably familiar
to some of you uh but for those who
don't know it's an International Bank it
operates in 10 retail markets and 40
wholesale markets and uh I've been at D
for the last three years working on the
app so U this is the uh login page of
the app uh there's quite a lot of
different things that you can do and
data science Powers uh some of these
features so for instance uh we predict
which transactions will come in we uh
categorize the transactions that uh have
occurred and we also personalize the uh
main page itself so uh I'm from the
personalization team and have been
working there as a data scientist as a
product owner and as a product data
scientist
um so in my time at in I've put multiple
models into production um but if I look
back at my time and uh I think if I
asked my manager as well he would agree
that the most impact I had in the
organization didn't come from actually
uh building those models um I think the
most valuable contributions that I've
made uh were a bit more vague a bit more
ephemerial uh but there there were
usually instances where I help helped
the team identify new problems uh to
work on or to actually prevent models
from going into production uh because
they weren't actually solving anything
um and I want to talk to you I want to
walk you through the framework that uh
I've come to um use in my day-to-day and
uh I hope that it's something that you
can take away as well so this is the
product development process and it's
probably familiar to many of you at
least at least the questions that are on
the slide so usually we all start with
the question of what is the problem
right is there a business need that
needs to be done are the costs maybe too
high um is there a customer uh problem
that can be satisfied and so once you
feel a bit sure about the problem you go
to the stage of thinking what is the
solution right how can we solve this
problem and that usually comes with a
few extra questions uh for instance what
is the interface and here it can be both
the UI but more generally speaking how
do you kind of make sure that the
information that you're producing gets
to where it needs to be and then also
what is the technical design and that
encompasses both the model design but
also the software engineering aspects of
it is it running properly is it
available uh and is it performance
enough and then at the end of it you
have the step where you try to actually
ask yourself is the solution that we
developed solving the original problem
and that's a very important part of this
chain because on every single of the
previous questions you make assumptions
because we can't know for sure if the
problem is 100% there or the interface
is 100% available and reliable so
usually um you have to make some
assumptions to uh make some progress but
the validation step only happens once
every time you go for the entire cycle
so there's a bit of a disbalance there
and to make things worse um a lot of
these assumptions essentially tie into
together but they're not made by a
single person so if you have a product
manager on your
team if you have a ux designer on your
team if you have a software engineer on
your team they all make those different
assumptions uh but they're all
responsible for only some of the
questions that you deal with so that
adds to the complexity and increases the
fact that something gets Lost in
Translation or you make decisions based
on incomplete information and I think
that's where um our role as data
scientists come in so if you're more of
a machine learning engineer uh you
obviously think about what is the model
to build um and uh how do we put it into
production how do we make sure it runs
but I think it's also your
responsibility to look at is this
actually solving the problem we
originally were intending to solve and
therefore this validation part is um
probably part of your or should be part
of your responsibilities if it isn't and
then the other profile that we have
that's the one I more closely associate
with is a product data scientist so
there you don't Focus as much on
building the models but you really want
to make sure that uh you answer this
question you help the team validate
faster and more reliably and I think
often times you also think with the
product manager or whoever other uh
whoever else is responsible for the
business decisions about what is the
problem that we should be solving and um
in my my talk today I want to walk you
through the things that you can do to
improve your chances of building
something that uh users want or
something that solves an actual business
need and um some of the things include
um pretty basic stuff like talking to
your customers um that's not necessarily
your responsibility as a data scientist
but I think you should make sure that at
least someone in your team is doing this
another thing is doing market research
and expert advice so an example would be
uh since we work in the personalization
team uh we need to get feedback back
from customers about whether they like
the content we show to them or not and
we could have gone through the entire
cycle and thought of the problem thought
of the solution do all of the stuff but
uh in practice what we did instead was
just look okay what are the other apps
that are kind of similar to the app that
we have uh which of them also show
content and how do they solve this
problem right so we did a bit of market
research and that helped us already get
up to speed and another thing is that
you can have experts that you talk to so
if you know people that already solved
problems similar to yours then I think
it's generally also good to try to seek
out um advice from them but then the
next three things are something that you
really should and can only do as a data
scientist and the first of them is
cycling through uh this entire chain
faster building early MVPs and releasing
as early as POS as possible another
thing is to make very specific
hypotheses before you set up experiments
and the last thing is to find validation
evidence in the data even before you
start building anything or uh putting
anything into production so these are
the things that you should do as a data
scientist and I'll walk through uh each
of them in a bit more detail with some
specific
examples so first of all cycling through
faster um and why we need to build MVPs
and launch MVPs as early as possible um
I'll talk I'll walk you through to two
different cases which I've worked on
during my time at in and both of them
had a very very different U length of
this uh MVP cycle so in the first
project it took us uh two months to
launch our MVP and in the second project
it took us only one week to launch the
MVP and I'll talk about why that uh what
were the outcomes of that difference so
first of all um let's start with the
case on the social ads
optimization um um back in 2020 uh when
Co started the cost of ads or social ads
started to increase because everything
moved to online everything became
e-commerce so uh there was much more
demand for uh social advertising and at
in we also noticed this and we wanted to
figure out how can we decrease that cost
so the problem was clear um and it was
more on the business side and then the
next step was to think about the
solution and we thought that that okay
so we select some customers and we push
them to the uh systems of Facebook and
Google to Target but if we pre-select
some customers and filter out the ones
that we really know don't have a
propensity to buy any of our products in
that sense we would um decrease the cost
because we target fewer people so that's
the solution that we thought about uh
and we thought about building a model
for this the interface to use was an
Excel with the customer IDs that we
share to the agency so uh I G has a
partnership with some agencies that
handles all of this uh putting the IDS
and the bids into the into the systems
and uh the the communication with them
happens through this Excel that's shared
every uh every few weeks on the
technical design we thought that okay so
we want to test whether we can do
something so let's not over complicate
things and let's just build a linear
regression on the gcp environment that
we have and uh use the model outputs to
um great the solution so that's all nice
but uh because we're working on gcp and
uh because in uh banking environment
there's quite a lot of um kind of we try
to be very careful with the data so
exporting from gcp takes some time all
of these kind of things uh all in all it
took us two months to build the MVP and
go through the cycle and unfortunately
um after those two months we realized
that no the solution that we built isn't
solving the original problem and then we
started digging so was it the model
performance or was it something else in
this entire chain so we tried to answer
the question of why did it fail and then
we figure out that the interface was
actually uh incorrect so um even though
we uh gave those customer IDs to the
agency the agency could only match 10%
of those IDs and therefore um kind of
any Improvement that we had was the was
divided by 10 and uh we didn't really
see the signal in the experiment so the
interface was invalid uh but it took us
2 months to realize this so what should
have happened instead so if instead of
building a linear regression on gcp we
would just have made a backof the
envelope calculation about which
products have the highest crossby with
the other products that we offer and
just make this kind calculation for
every single customer which you can do
on I mean just uh via a simple SQL
interface that would have been enough
right that should have been our MVP and
then we would have launched this thing
within one week and we would have found
out that the interface doesn't work uh
much much earlier um so this was a case
where it took us two months to realize
that a very basic uh assumption in that
chain was wrong the other case is they
uh uh happen two years later uh after
after I've worked on multiple projects I
started working on the login intent
prediction model and there um I tried to
extrapolate and bring with me some of
the learnings from the previous project
so the problem was that uh we have quite
a few features in our uh app and
customers use a lot of them but not all
are available at a single click away so
some features like uh predicting your
future transactions you need to click
two or three times to get to that
feature so we thought that there's a
customer problem of fast laning right so
because some features are multiple
clicks away we thought that if we give
them a shortcut and they can get to what
they want to do uh in just one click
that's going to have a positive um
positive effect on the customer
experience um so the solution we thought
of was to predict which feature the
customer will use when they log in and
show them a shortcut um about this
feature um having
kind of the learnings from the past
instead of uh thinking of an interface
where we build a completely new UI
component and ship it to production and
all of that stuff um I instead wish the
team to just reuse an existing component
that we have so here the message that
you see that's the example of the
shortcuts that we showed to customers in
the experiments and uh essentially it's
just uh it's something that we set up
literally within one hour because we
just had to create the copy input in the
hyperlink um and then in terms of the
technical design so how would we predict
uh which feature the customers will use
we literally just ran an SQL query to
find per customer what is the feature
use the most and uh that was the feature
for which we showed you the shortcut
nothing fancy it wasn't a model we
didn't train it on gcp it was literally
just an SQL query and because of these
design decisions that we made we were
ready within one week so within one week
customers were seeing this I think
around 10,000 customers saw this
um and we started to get um data uh to
evaluate our experiment unfortunately in
this case we also didn't uh validate our
problem because the Sol because the
customers didn't end up using the
shortcut but after some deliberation and
after some discussions we realized that
actually the problem isn't really there
so we really overestimated how bad is it
for customers to have something two
clicks away especially because they're
already very active using that feature
uh but instead of abandoning this
project we got this learning and we
thought okay so we should use this model
uh or kind of this design to find
customers that would be using this
feature but for whatever reason are
coming to the app and we should try to
nudge them to use the app more uh
because we know that they would for
instance use the K FR feature that
predicts your future f future
transactions and the idea is now to
reach out to them by email or the other
channels that we have so in this case it
only took us one week to get that
learning and um I think it also then
even though the outcome was negative it
didn't really have any impact on the
morale of the team right if you work on
something for two months and then it
doesn't really work it has a different
impact on the team then if you work only
for one week you did this experiment and
then you move on to the next thing so
that's one thing that you can do to um
validate your ideas faster and uh in my
experience this is one of the most
impact things that uh you can do as a
product team so um I think as a data
scientist you should really push your
team to ship things faster uh because in
data science there's so much uncertainty
about so many things so is your model
performing well is the interface correct
and the best thing that you can do is
just to uh cycle through this
faster however that's not the only thing
that you can do so the other part is
about making very specific hypotheses
before you launch experiment and I'll
explain what I mean here on on an
example as well um so as a product data
scientist you're responsible for this
validation moment and figuring out if
the solution is solving the problem uh
usually that happens by running
experiments right so you think of a
metric that would capture whether the
experiment is a success or not that's
how you know if the solution is solving
the problem or not then you think of the
experiment design you Define the
experiment group the control group um
just do some power analysis to find the
optimal duration of the experiment and
the sample size and once you went
through all of these things there's two
outcomes right so either yes you run the
experiment it's all nice you know that
your model or your feature is solving
the problem it was intended to solve or
no you don't see the uplift that you
were expecting your ab test is not
conclusive all of these things right if
it's the first case and uh you get the
positive results usually that's the end
of the story you move on you
productionize you improve the model all
that stuff but if you didn't get the
positive results then the next step is
thinking of what went wrong right why
did the experiment fail and this is
where um making very specific hypothesis
becomes important because if you just
say okay we built this model that
predicts um customer intent right so we
know why people came into the app and
what they want to do and we expect them
to click on that button more if that's
the way you phrase your hypothesis then
afterwards when it fails you don't
really have a clue of where to start
looking for the reasons of that failure
but to avoid that I would say you need
to start with why so move that question
to the beginning of your chain so before
you launched an experiment think of why
do I expect this experiment to be a
success and coming back to the example
of the login intent prediction we could
phrase it that uh we expect a very
specific CTR so let's say 10% CTR on the
shortcut because we thought that
customers will uh come to the fature Via
this path instead of the other path and
that the CTR will increase over time
because there is a bit of an ads
blindness effect to that component that
we reused right so it's very very
specific specific H hypothesis and when
we start with such an hypothesis and go
through the cycle and get a negative
answer we know what to check because we
made the hypothesis very correct very
very concrete right so we check was the
ctrr actually
10% was the um proportion of the traffic
to the feature uh increasing through
that shortcut or uh was the CTR
increasing over time right so in our
hypothesis we had three specific points
and uh because we defined them so
concretely we can check them afterwards
so um again in my experience these kind
of things they really help to um make
sure that your ab tests are set up
properly and that you don't have to
restart and waste time because of
that um finally the last thing that you
can do um as a product data scientist is
to find validation evidence in past data
so before you launch any experiments and
that concerns more the part of think
what is the problem uh so in my
experience I work with our product lead
and I help him on Discovery so part of
my responsibility is to come up with new
problems to solve and uh usually my
workflow starts with making some um idea
about what could I find in the data and
then just go and look for it so again
I'll try to explain on example so so
that it's more clear
um we uh because we work in
personalization uh we work with multiple
channels because C customers are present
on uh not just in the app but a lot of
customers use email uh to interact with
the messages we sent them or with chat
and the hypothesis that we had was that
um some customers have a channel they
prefer and so um when we show them some
recommendations maybe we should show
them through one channel and not through
another Channel and so my hypothesis was
that if we look into the data we will
find some customers that use the email
more but the app not as much and then
the other way around so they respond to
our messages in the app a lot but not an
email so I had the simple hypothesis
then I started looking into the data and
then I found this right so as you on
aggregate as customers use the email
Channel more they also tend to use the
app Channel more and I could have
stopped there and could have come back
to our product lead and said no so
there's no evidence of customers having
a preferred Channel we shouldn't proceed
with this let's just uh drop this and
move on to the next project but I had a
bit of an intuition that personally I
felt like I fell into a bucket that
really prefers to be contacted via the
app like I'm really annoyed when
anything uh commercial or anything about
the new features that uh in or any other
company launched I really don't like
those emails my emails the sanctuary
where it's kind of like my to-do list
all of that stuff so I was kind of
confused that we don't see this so I
decided to dig in a bit deeper and uh
my thought was that probably there's a
bit of an aggregation effect and we need
to First separate the customers into
more selfsimilar clusters so um the next
thing I did was I took all of our
customers and uh just by became means
clustered uh based on the customer
features that we have so for uh
Simplicity sake let's think there's the
number of transactions that you do in a
year and the total assets that you own
so if we use those two features we can
get quite clear clusters of customers
um so again we have the same question
right do customers have a channel they
prefer to be contacted through and now
that we have those clusters I can run
the same calculation and I found the
evidence that I was looking for so the
majority of customers as they use the
email Channel more they also use the app
Channel more so it's the big orange
cluster but then there are two small
smaller clusters that did show CH uh
signs of Channel preference so um then
kind of looking at this it was a very
different story from what I saw before
and I couldn't have come to this without
using a bit more of Advanced Techniques
for U for the analysis and uh I think I
also see sometimes data scientists
shying away from these kind of analyses
because they think that oh a data
analyst can do this because it's just a
you know you don't need a model to run
the to run this but I think what data
scientists don't often realize is that
to any analysis there's many layers of
complexity you can go as deep as you
want and sometimes you do need a bit of
a different skill set to come to the
conclusions that will help your team uh
work on features and work on problems
that are um actually worth solving so
here in this case we uh concluded that
yes there are signs of Channel
preference and we proceeded to working
on this
problem um so my key takeaways for you
today are very simple and and nothing
there is related to mlops uh first I
would say that be conscious of the fact
that you make assumptions on every
single step of your product development
process and be conscious of the fact
that we don't validate them as often as
we should be so validate all of these
assumptions and just be conscious of
that um another um thing that I would
advise you to do is just to launch stuff
early because done imperfectly is way
better than done late um um I think
there's we don't realize this but
there's an opportunity cost uh to
working on certain problems and if you
spend two months on something that
really doesn't make sense it can have
compounding effects in the future so
just try to launch as early as possible
but at the same time try to be a bit
conscious of what you're testing right
so make very specific hypotheses before
you uh launch anything to production and
finally don't look down on some types of
work right I think as data scientist
sometimes we think okay we're we're
trained in math and statistics and
computer science we have all of this
knowledge about you know how to do
regularization or transfer learning so
we should be spending most of our time
on building models or then also on uh
making sure those models run in
production those are important things
but there's also sometimes the less
fancy stuff like doing an analysis or
just stepping back thinking about the
problem chatting with some people maybe
chatting with customers so don't shy
away from those things and try to use
your skill set and your tool set for
things other than model
building um that's the end of my
presentation um you can connect to me on
LinkedIn or Twitter and if you like the
slides uh you can find them on the
GitHub repo um that's it for my talk so
thanks a lot for listening and I'm happy
to answer any
questions
[Applause]